The FDA says a
popular ingredient
in many over-the-counter
medicines for colds and allergies
doesn't work.
Concluding in a panel this week
that the main ingredient in those drugs
is ineffective in tablet form.
Phenol.
Ephron is used in products
like Benadryl, allergy plus congestion,
Sudafed PE and Vicks snacks,
according to the FDA.
These products
generally nearly generated rather nearly
$1.8 billion in sales last year alone.
Dr.
Jane Morgan, a cardiologist,
joining me right now.
Dr. Morgan, good to see you.
So a lot of doctors have questioned
the effectiveness of
Ephron final Ephron for a very long time.
So how did it find its way
in these products?
And so, you know,
that was approved
back in 1972,
where the criteria was
a little less stringent.
But we started to
have some pushback against it
around 2006, 2007
and then 2016
really started generating data to refute
the original claims in 1972.
And so it's really
come to this point here in 2023
with finally looking at that data
and saying, you know what?
It really doesn't work.
It's not any better than placebo
in the oral formulation.
The reason for that is
if you take it by mouth in any form
your liver
and gut metabolize, in other words
degrade it to such a degree
until there's
not much active compound left.
So it still takes way.
That's right.
You can still take the nasal spray
but you cannot take anything orally.
Okay.
So do you see that drug even
being reclassified
as a result of this discovery
or acknowledgment?
And so we will wait
for the comment portion of the FDA
and then their final ruling on
whether or not
they will actually ask companies
to reformulate their products
or whether it will be a total recall
and say all of these
have to be removed from the shelves.
Remember,
this is an entire industry there.
Over 250 products
over the counter that contain phenol.
And so it's going to be very impactful.
But we also have to have
products available
that are effective
and actually do what we say
they're going to do.
Well,
I wonder what that's going to
how that will impact consumers.
I mean, when you have a cold,
you have symptoms
related to a cold or flu or something
to those degrees,
you generally
going to reach
for some of these products.
But now there may be some reticence
about trusting any of them,
even if they don't have
this ingredient in them.
You know, I have an opposing view.
We should actually have
more confidence in our system now
because we have the ability
to go back and say,
you know what, we made a mistake
and you know what?
Things have changed in 50 years,
and we're going to acknowledge
that science has advanced
and that we have new information
and we're going to act
on that information.
If, in fact, you have a cold,
you can ask for products
that have pseudoephedrine in them.
Those are over the counter.
But behind the counter,
you have to ask the pharmacist for them.
You don't need a prescription
because they do have value
in making street meth,
also products
with glass, venison in them.
And so those are still ingredients
that are very effective
for people who have nasal congestion.
So there is still
some good stuff out there, you say.
Okay, now
a big concern, of course, this fall
and of course, this winter
as we're spending more time inside
COVID and the latest strain
there is a new COVID
vaccine already on the market. Right.
When do we start getting that?
So that vaccine is available now.
And in fact, we saw
the FDA
say that
this really should be broadly available
to everybody.
Six months of age and older.
And then the CDC came behind them
and supported it
and said universally
this should be available.
We thought that
originally it was only going
to be targeted to immunocompromised
and specialized groups.
That was an option.
But it'll be universally available
and is available right now.
As of yesterday to everyone
age, months and older,
six months and older.
And we'll see it be broadly available
now that manufacturing
will really ramp up
in the next week or two. All right.
Get those shots.
Once again here we go.
All right.
Dr. Jane Morgan, great to see you.
Nice to see you. Thanks for.